Hikaru Nakamura bopped his head in
satisfaction calculated a devastating
attack to gain a key Victory and a
ticket to the finals of the winners
bracket in the chessable master in the
losers bracket Levon aronian
outmaneuvered Vladimir felicev and
squeezed out a win with a dominating
Advantage Magnus Carlsen faced off
against Lake Huang Lim in the other
losers bracket match unfamiliar
territory for the current world champion
very precise chess was played by both
players leading to nothing but draws in
Armageddon Magnus forced to draw with
black advancing and keeping his chances
alive in the winners bracket Fabiana
caruana and vladislav artimia battled
out in hard fought games fought with
Dangerous Time trouble in Armageddon
Fabiano caruana proved why he is a human
calculator the game was eventually drawn
giving Carolina the victory in an
American Showdown Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so were aggressive from the
get-go many chances were on the board
but all resolved into draws Hikaru
nakamur refused to take a loss and
survive some difficult positions in the
one decisive game so offered to draw
early on when it was even but Hikaru
denied a win was on the board and
following a blunder by cell